[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARY GROVE: Hi, everyone.
How are you today?
Doing well?
So my name is Mary
Grove, and I'm
the director of Google
for Entrepreneurs,
and it's my pleasure to
welcome you to today's talk.
Before we get started, just
a quick administrative note.
We are live streaming
and recording this,
so if I could ask you to
please silence your phones
and computers, so the pings
don't get captured as well,
that would be great.
So it's my pleasure to introduce
two of the amazing leaders
in our industry who really need
no introduction, David Cohen
and Brad Feld of Techstars.
Techstars has been one of
Google Entrepreneurs' strongest
partners for several
years now, and we
are huge fans and
appreciative of all
they've done to develop
startup ecosystems worldwide.
Just a bit of
background on David.
David is the co-founder
and co-CEO of Techstars.
He is a serial entrepreneur
with two successful exits.
He founded Pinpoint
Technologies, acquired
by ZOLL Medical Corporation, and
Earfeeder.com, a music service
that sold to SonicSwap.
David is also an active startup
advocate, advisor, author,
board member.
You can read many
of his thoughts
on these topics at
davidgcohen.com.
He and Brad also coauthored "Do
More Faster: Techstars Lessons
to Accelerate Your Startup."
A bit of background on Brad.
Brad is the co-founder of
Techstars, an early stage
investor and entrepreneur
himself since 1987.
Prior to co-founding
the Foundry Group,
he co-founded Mobius Venture
Capital and Intensity Ventures.
Brad is active on
several boards.
He is the chair of the
National Center for Women
and Information
Technology, and he's
on the boards of Path Forward,
The Kauffman Fellows, and Defy
Ventures.
Brad is also a prolific
speaker and writer.
He's written a number of
books as part of the Startup
Revolution Series.
You can check out his thoughts
and more at the blogs Feld
Thoughts and Venture Deals.
So without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming David
Cohen and Brad Feld.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID COHEN: Thank
you very much.
MARY GROVE: Lots of familiar
faces in the room for you guys.
DAVID COHEN: Yes.
MARY GROVE: Welcome
back to Google.
BRAD FELD: It feels
warm and comfortable.
MARY GROVE: [LAUGHS] Absolutely.
So lots of topics I'd love
to cover today and also
take questions from
our audience as well.
So let's start just with
a bit of background.
I'd love to hear a
bit about the founding
story behind Techstars.
What was your mission
when you started,
and how has that evolved?
DAVID COHEN: Sure.
The whole thing has
been an evolution.
But the founding story
that's kind of fun
is I had never met Brad
before at that time,
but I was reading his blog,
like I'm sure a lot of people
do still, because it's
an amazing resource.
Had this idea around
Techstars being
this mentorship-driven
accelerator process,
but really didn't have
much beyond that in terms
of the network around it.
So I went to get a meeting with
you, and your assistant said,
no problem.
Brad does these
random days that he'll
meet with literally anybody.
So I guess I qualified for that.
MARY GROVE: Great, great.
DAVID COHEN: And it took
me just a short four months
to get the meeting.
The assistant picked a time.
It was a 15-minute meeting.
I remember, because you were
doing them back to back,
all day long.
And I walked into that meeting
and slid a piece of paper
across the table,
folded in half,
and it was basically
the idea for Techstars.
And I said, I'd love to have
you involved in some way.
And 10 minutes into the
meeting, we were done
because Brad had said, I'm in.
I love the idea, as long as
you're not a crook or a flake,
because we had just met.
So I'm not sure where you
are on those topics today--
BRAD FELD: Still learning.
DAVID COHEN: Still learning.
MARY GROVE: What year was this?
DAVID COHEN: Oh, jeez.
BRAD FELD: 2006.
DAVID COHEN: Yeah, '06, I think.
And from there, Brad helped
connect a lot of the mentors
into that first program
that would later
become known as an accelerator.
That word didn't
exist back then,
and we apologize for
creating a word that
got used and overused.
And of course, from
there, that network built.
We built the
accelerator programs,
and it's really grown
from there over 10 years.
MARY GROVE: I'm interested in
the evolution of accelerators
generally.
And we saw this
big proliferation
five or six years ago.
We saw a lot of the
business models sort of fail
around that.
What's your current
thought on landscape?
What models are working?
What have you found
that works well
in terms of running, scaling,
growing accelerators?
BRAD FELD: I would
have a prelude to that
and then let you talk
about current reality.
The evolution of Techstars from
where we were in 2007 to where
we are in 2018 is
important because its
like the evolution of many
really successful startups,
right?
You created it with a premise.
I would suggest that most
startups have no idea
whether the premise is
valid or not, regardless
of the enthusiasm
of the founders,
including us at the time.
We also had our view
of a downside case,
where the downside case was
we'd lose our all our money,
but we'd make some friends.
So our worst case in
running that first program
in Boulder in 2007 was that
we'd make some new friends
with entrepreneurs.
The 2007 program
was very successful,
and we decided to do exactly
the same thing in 2008.
So rather than go on a journey
to start to expand or turn it
into something different,
we're like, yeah,
we did a bunch of things right.
We did a bunch of things wrong.
We can improve a lot of stuff.
Let's do this experiment again.
And we didn't really start
expanding Techstars until 2009,
when we got pulled by some
entrepreneurs to Boston.
And that was when we
did a second program.
So all of a sudden,
we've got a program
in Boulder, a program in Boston.
We then got pulled to Seattle,
so we had a third program.
We then got pulled to New York,
so we had a fourth program.
Language is important here.
I used the word
pull deliberately,
because we were having,
essentially, other people who
we wanted to participate
with pull us to do it,
versus us say, we're going
to expand into these vectors.
The same phenomenon
happened with
our first corporate partners.
We had never really thought
hard about corporate accelerator
or the dynamic of what those
relationships might look like.
And the very first one was
somebody who came to us
and said, we want to
do what you're doing,
but with our ecosystem.
Programs like Startup
Weekend, which--
MARY GROVE: That's how we met.
BRAD FELD: That's how we met,
and Google for Entrepreneurs
has been an incredible supporter
of it for a very long time.
Similar kind of
phenomenon, right?
It was something that the very
first program happened in 2007
in Boulder during
that first Boulder
program, because a
couple of people said,
eh, let's try this.
Let's see if it works.
I have no idea if it's
interesting or not,
but what the hell.
My role in that first one was
that I provided the funding
for the food.
MARY GROVE: That's very
important to us here at Google.
BRAD FELD: And I should say
I provided half the funding
for the food, because
my partner, Seth Levine,
provided the other half of
the funding for the food.
But we hung out.
You sort of have this thing
that unfolds over time,
and it gets pulled in lots
of different directions.
And I think that's a key
operating perspective for not
just Techstars, but for
many of the companies that
go through Techstars
or many startups,
is that the ones that are
really successful get pulled.
And as a startup, if
you feel like you're
pushing into something, looking
harder for the place where
all of a sudden--
like to say, people won't
let you hold onto it.
They just want to rip
it out of your hands
because they want it
so badly, whether it's
a product or a service
or a technology.
And as that phenomenon
starts happening, then
layering a strategy
of what you're
doing on top of that is key
because now you have enough
to work with, versus maybe it's
a historical business context.
Create your framework.
Figure out your strategy.
What's your product going to be?
What's the market going to be?
And you basically
create this hypothesis
completely in the
absence of any real data.
And so our journey,
really, from the beginning
to current reality--
and I'll hand it to you to
talk about current reality
and what success looks like--
is the dynamics of pull
versus the dynamics of push.
MARY GROVE: It's an
excellent observation.
And to that point,
David, in terms
of painting a portrait
of current reality,
there's so many
components to Techstars,
from the city programs, to
the corporate accelerators,
to the community programs,
the venture fund.
Can you just give us the
quick-- paint us the map of who
is Techstars today?
What's your scale and reach?
DAVID COHEN: I'll tie it
back to the other topic.
So today, we're 10,
11 years in almost.
People know us for
the accelerators.
There's about 40
of those that we
run, so about 400
companies a year
being accepted into those in 11
countries, about 40 locations.
The tens of thousands of
companies that apply there,
we're picking from that view.
So a lot of those are coming
through the Startup Weekend
activity, which now, having
started in Boulder, Colorado
the same summer that
Techstars started,
has grown to be this
global phenomenon as well.
That's in about 1,000 events
a year now in 120 countries,
so literally all over the world.
And then you also have
the venture capital piece,
which follows on in
our own companies.
It's capitalist-targeted and
participating in their success
as they grow.
So those are the pieces.
And when we think
about it, today
is very different from how
we think about it back then.
I think if it were an
accelerator in Boulder,
Colorado, it wouldn't be
a very exciting business.
But what it is as a product
today is really a network.
And the way we
describe it is it's
the worldwide network that
helps entrepreneurs succeed.
And to do that, we
have to be everywhere
that entrepreneurs are and
want to succeed and build
products along their
journey of entrepreneurship,
from the moment
they are inspired,
all the way through IPO.
And so today, a lot
of scope and scale.
Back then, I think like
so many accelerators today
on the market, thinking about
it as a thing and a place
that does 10 companies a year
or whatever, it turns out
wasn't really a business.
The real business is all
of that put together.
We've seen tremendous growth
in the corporate vector
that Brad was describing.
We're running accelerators now
for lots of major corporations
and really getting to work with
some amazing entrepreneurs,
to the point where
today, when you think
about the scale of it, about
1 in 20 of the series A's that
happen in the US, the $5
million and up type financing,
start with us as
the first investor.
So it really is--
MARY GROVE: That's
pretty remarkable.
DAVID COHEN: It
really is something
that now has impact across
the entrepreneurial ecosystem.
BRAD FELD: I'd add a
couple of things into that.
Key on the word network
that David used.
And one of the operating
principles from the beginning
was this idea of a network
model versus any sort
of hierarchical model.
A book that I wrote in 2012,
called "Startup Communities,"
talked about this notion of
how startup communities evolve
as networks versus hierarchies.
You can't organize them.
There isn't a CEO of
a startup community.
And for Techstars,
we tried to build
this very, very broad network.
As part of that
phenomenon, we've
scaled horizontally
instead of vertically,
which is something that should
be near and dear to Google,
because I think
Google is probably
maybe one of the first companies
to really start to scale
horizontally, in terms of
technical architecture,
in a significant way.
And if you think
about it, instead
of having 10 companies go
through the Boulder program
in 2007 and 50 companies go
in 2018, we have 10 companies
go through the Boulder program.
And that horizontal
scaling, where
each program has 10
companies, but now we
have 40 companies happening
all over the world,
generates 400 companies a year
that, effectively, Techstars
is investing in through
the accelerator program.
It allows that network
to grow worldwide,
and it's built on
a principle, which
I know that Mary shares
from all the stuff
we've done in the past, which
is that entrepreneurship can
and should exist everywhere,
and that you can build
vibrant startup communities
and significant companies
all over the world.
And I think that's
been something
we've included in our thinking
from the very beginning.
In 2007, the idea of starting
a company in Boulder, Colorado,
not that insane, but nobody
would look at Boulder and say
Boulder is this incredible
place to start companies.
MARY GROVE: People are certainly
headed your way these days.
BRAD FELD: Well, and today,
Boulder, as a data point,
if you look at what I think is
a really interesting number,
which is not the amount
of dollars invested
in the geography or the
amount of companies created
in the geography, but if you
think about entrepreneurship
and entrepreneurship over
a long period of time,
it's the number of companies
per capita in a geography.
And if you actually look at the
number of companies per capita
in different cities
around the world,
Boulder's at the
top of that list.
Not number two,
not number three,
but at the top of the list.
It's a relatively small place
with this incredible density.
But it's not only that.
Go back to this network model.
Google has now a very
big presence in Boulder.
Just finished a
campus there that
can house a couple
of thousand people.
I think it's 1,200 people
or so going to 3,000.
And that came from
the acquisition
of a 40-person company
in 2004 called @Last
that was based in Boulder.
DAVID COHEN: You may
know it as SketchUp.
BRAD FELD: SketchUp, right.
And so the expansion of
that and the integration--
by the way, Google in Boulder
is an extraordinary corporate
citizen.
Scott Green, we have the
local people of the year,
entrepreneur of the
year, business person
of the year award.
He got one of the couple
of awards yesterday.
And Scott's a good example
of that network model
and continuing to
engage, not just
in the context of whatever
I'm going to do here
is for me as a Google employee,
but I'm part of this geography,
and so I want to make sure
that the activity and vector
and interaction around
technology, entrepreneurship,
innovation is something
that's broadly distributed.
I think that's been an operating
principle of this as well
for us.
MARY GROVE: Let
me build on that.
You talked about the density.
You talked about
the talent pool.
Boulder's a great example.
So let's zoom out a little bit
and talk about your perspective
at the ecosystem level.
And you have been really
investing globally
in these communities.
Can I ask, what are some
of the key ingredients,
aside from talent
and density, that you
think are required for
startup communities
to really thrive and take off?
BRAD FELD: So I have a very,
very simple starting point
from the book that
I wrote in 2012.
I'm in the process of writing a
sequel to it that will come out
later this year around the
notion of how to create
a startup community anywhere.
And it's been very interesting.
A lot of what I've learned over
the last six or seven years
has also come from the work with
Startup Weekend and UP Global
and Google for Entrepreneurs.
So there's a lot of
reflective learning.
The core principles
are really easy.
And they're a little
bit counter-intuitive
to conventional wisdom.
Conventional wisdom
was that you had
to have a really strong research
university at the center of it,
or else nothing would happen.
Another piece of
conventional wisdom
was that it had to
be in a place where
there was a lot of
top-down economic activity
and influence.
And it turns out, neither of
those two things are true.
The key principles are first
that the leaders of the startup
community have to
be entrepreneurs.
So you have to have this
motive force of entrepreneurs
who are continually
investing and building
in their startup community.
Not government, not
university, not big companies,
not nonprofits that are
organized around it.
Those are all support functions.
I called them feeders
in that book, which
is a word I probably
wouldn't use again,
because it was too pejorative
relative to how people
interpreted it.
But this idea that
they're different.
They play different
roles in this.
If you don't have entrepreneurs
who are playing that leadership
role, the startup community
won't grow and make progress.
The second is that you have
to have a very long-term view,
at least 20 years.
And when people talk
about, for example,
Silicon Valley and the
Bay Area, the Bay Area
is 110 or 120 years into
its entrepreneurial journey.
You really have to have
this very long-term view
of what you're trying to do.
And so many
organizations, again,
university, government,
even big companies,
run on rhythms that
are short-term.
Right?
Quarterly, annually.
How much progress did
we make this year?
What are the metrics that
show that our startup
community grew?
It doesn't matter.
Play a much longer game.
The third is that you have
to be inclusive of anyone who
wants to engage at any level.
And the notion of
inclusion and diversity
and inclusion in the
last, say, 24 months,
has started to become
something that is
a front-of-mind conversation.
But this idea that anyone,
regardless of gender,
race, socioeconomic background,
educational background,
experience, can be and should
be able to engage in the startup
community is key.
And in fact, the
more diversity you
have going on in that
mix, the more vibrant
that startup community is.
And then the last
is that you have
to have this supersaturation
of activities and events
going on all the time
that engage people
around entrepreneurship,
not just entrepreneurs.
So it's, again, this
notion of inclusion
around the system
of anyone who has
any interest in
entrepreneurship and innovation.
The interesting challenge here,
which is really important,
is that as entrepreneurial
activity increases,
and as the startup communities
become more vibrant,
often the signal-to-noise ratio
gets really out of whack--
a lot of noise,
not enough signal.
And you see this especially
in places like the Bay Area,
where there's just an enormous
amount of stuff going on.
You can't figure out
where you should engage,
or you can engage in
everything and then
never get anything done, because
you're spending all your time
running around doing stuff
that has nothing to do
with making forward progress.
And so in the context
of the startup community
and the maturation
of them, making sure
that the signal stays
high and making sure
that the leaders
are not necessarily
curating what happens,
but that everybody
can do what they want,
but that there's still
an engagement model that's such,
including by the people who
have been engaged and
involved in the startup
community for a
long period of time.
MARY GROVE: Thank you, Brad.
And we can't wait to read more
about that in your next book,
which comes out when this year?
BRAD FELD: Later.
MARY GROVE: Later this year.
You heard it here first.
DAVID COHEN: Once you write it.
BRAD FELD: Later this year.
MARY GROVE: So David, building
upon that, Brad touched briefly
upon diversity inclusion and
its importance to Techstars.
And today is, of course,
International Women's Day.
Thanks for spending it with us.
Can you talk to us a little
bit, David, about the culture
of Techstars and how you are
addressing building inclusion
within your team, part one.
And part two, how
do you advise--
you're working with
entrepreneurs who are building
companies from the ground up.
How do you advise them to think
about layering this mentality
in from the get-go?
DAVID COHEN: That's
funny, because we
didn't think enough
about it, I think,
in the beginning of Techstars.
There are four founders.
They all happen to be men.
And I think thinking
about it early is
that the first piece of advice.
So we've been building
a lot of content
and a lot of
process and programs
to help startups who are at day
one to think about this stuff.
Because in the end, it's
not only the right thing
to be thinking about
and do, but it's
going to make the
companies better,
which is going to make
us better as investors
in those companies,
So over the years, we've
certainly worked on ourselves,
so that when we work
on our portfolio,
it sort of hits home with them.
I think four years
ago now, something
like that, we launched
something called the Techstars
Foundation, which Google's
been a huge supporter of.
And that is focused on
diversity inclusion in tech.
And so we've been
experimenting with what's
the right model there.
We think one of the
things we're good at
is identifying scalable
organizations, startups,
that can go and have impact.
If we can do that by
finding organizations
early on that are going to
have this impact long term,
then we can support them, and
that's useful and helpful.
So we funded that with a
bunch of our own money.
Our companies have funded it.
We've had incredible
support from partners.
And today, it's a
reasonable-sized foundation
that has made on the
order of 10 or so grants,
but also has its own programs
to try to help have an impact.
Very early one of those
was Defy Ventures,
which is now something that the
whole venture community really
understands and talks about.
But back then, we were a
very early supporter of it.
So I think we can play
that role in helping
identifying something
that can have an impact.
What Defy does, Brad's
now super involved,
so maybe you can do their
commercial, if you'd like.
MARY GROVE: It's an
amazing organization.
DAVID COHEN: It's a lot of fun.
BRAD FELD: So happy to.
And then I'll make another
comment specifically
on the gender diversity dynamic.
That's something that
I've learned from my time
at NC WIT, which Google also has
been the long-term support on.
Defy provides
entrepreneur programs
for people who are incarcerated.
And a bunch of Google folks
have gone to Defy programs now.
A couple of hundred--
200, 300?
And so it's become--
Rick and I have been
friends for a long time.
And I think the first program--
you went to the one in Lancaster
that I went to the first time,
right?
So we both went for the first
time to the same program.
And what you do--
DAVID COHEN: So you've
been in prison together.
BRAD FELD: We've been
in prison together.
The program is
called Training EITs,
or Entrepreneurs In Training.
So the people who
are incarcerated
go through a six-month
process that's in the prison.
It's an educational program.
In California, there's quite
a wide number of programs.
There's a couple of
other states where
it's pretty prevalent now.
Colorado and Nebraska
are two of the ones
that are growing very quickly.
That six-month
program has a bunch
of interim mentoring periods.
They're sort of business
mentoring activity.
The curriculum is called
Become CEO of Your Life,
and the idea is around the
notion of second chances.
So there's a book
that just came out
last week called
"Second Chances"
by Cat Hoke, who's
the CEO of Defy.
And it's Cat's story,
but Cat's story
against the backdrop of
her own second chance
and against the backdrop of
giving people who have been
incarcerated second chances.
The culmination is graduation
day, which is a full day.
It was 12 hours for us.
We spent it at a prison,
the first one in Lancaster.
That was a level 4 maximum
security prison with 50 EITs.
There were about 75 volunteers.
And it's a combination
of a pitch competition,
a graduation, and then a bunch
of socialization exercises.
And for those of us who
were the volunteers,
you do a day like that in
any sort of new context,
and maybe you'll have one
insight or two insights,
and you'll get those
insights over and over again
throughout the
course of the day.
So you're like, wow, I never
thought of the world that way
before, but then
that gets repeated.
My experience, the first time
I did this program with Defy
was I had 20
different epiphanies
over the course of the day.
They just come at you from all
kinds of different directions
and all kinds of
different contexts.
And it's a reflective
phenomenon.
So the EITs are having
the same experience
that you're having in terms of
multiple epiphanies from them
and how you engage.
Here's a great example
from a program we just
did in Colorado, where
our governor, Governor
Hickenlooper, came to it.
And there's an exercise
called Walk the Line, where
you get a bunch of
questions asked,
and if the answer is
yes, you go to the line.
If the answer is no, you
walk back from the line.
And the questions
become pretty intense.
But one of them was, have
you ever been in jail?
And our governor
walks up to the line.
And of course, all the
EITs are on the line.
And they're looking at each
other like, our governor?
And he admitted it?
Right?
MARY GROVE: What
was his story there?
Was he--
BRAD FELD: You don't
ask the story, right?
By the way, his team, of which
it was a half dozen people,
they were like, what the fuck?
Our governor just
walked to the line.
But you have that moment
over and over again.
So it's extraordinarily
powerful.
And if you have
any interest in it,
Defy Ventures is the
name of the organization.
And I'm Brad@Feld.com, so
you can send me a note,
and I'll get you
plugged into it.
DAVID COHEN: It's
creating entrepreneurs
where there were none.
And the impact of it is--
I don't remember the numbers.
You may know them.
But recidivism,
meaning you're going
to go back to jail
once you're released,
that rate is very
high, normally.
MARY GROVE: I think it's like 3%
or 4% after the program, right?
DAVID COHEN: Now, after Defy,
those people, it's like 3%.
BRAD FELD: Yeah.
70% in-- I think it's
in California, maybe
US, 70% recidivism within
five years for people
who have had violent crimes.
It's under 5% if they've gone
through the Defy program.
And it's enough numbers
now where that's actually
a relative statistic.
DAVID COHEN: You try
to support things
like that are going to have
this long-term scalable impact.
BRAD FELD: Really
change how things work.
And, by the way, doing a
pitch competition with--
the prisons I've been in have
been all men-- with these guys,
is absolutely fascinating.
Because you see these
guys who are totally
comfortable in certain contexts
just completely terrified,
nervous, uncomfortable
and having
to work through that and
just their own self-esteem
that they're working through
that in a different context
than wherever they land.
The other one I just
wanted to do quickly
was National Center for Women
and Information Technology,
especially in the context of
International Women's Day.
I've been involved
in that organization
for over a decade, chair
for a number of years.
It's about a $10 million a
year nonprofit, based also
in Boulder, but worldwide.
And its goal is to help
more girls and women get
involved in computer science.
It started in the mid-2000s,
so before people were really
focusing on that.
It's an organization
that's been very inclusive.
So instead of it trying to
control the programs, much
of the money that we raise,
we give to other organizations
to fund and help support
programs they're doing.
As part of that, I learned
a very powerful thing
that is said some,
but I don't think
it's being said
enough right now,
around the dynamics
of roles men can
play in the context
of gender diversity.
And it's especially
true, when you
have to claim your own identity
as a 50-year-old white guy,
I mean, that's what I am, and
that's what I'm going to be.
DAVID COHEN: 50?
BRAD FELD: 52.
DAVID COHEN: Oh.
You're trying to take
a couple of years off.
MARY GROVE: Ouch, ouch.
DAVID COHEN: I just
want to call it out.
BRAD FELD: 50ish.
MARY GROVE: Who's counting?
DAVID COHEN: I'm barely in
my 40s, so I just wanted to--
BRAD FELD: The phrase we started
using a long time ago at NC WIT
through--
NC WIT's a research-based
organization,
so they've done a ton
of research around this.
And if you're interested,
ncwit.org is the website,
and just do a search
for male advocate.
And the phrase today that's
being used is male allies.
I think it's a more accessible
phrase that male advocate.
But the phrase we used
for a number of years
was male advocate.
And this notion of the
mistakes so many men make
around gender diversity is
they try to solve the problem.
Hi, here I am.
I'm now going to
solve this problem.
And that's completely wrong.
The right approach, from an
advocacy or ally approach
is hi, here I am.
I understand and acknowledge
that there's a problem.
I'm going to participate
in helping find
a solution to this problem.
And this notion of being
an advocate or an ally,
rather than the one who's
trying to control or develop,
is so incredibly important.
And I think it's one
of the reasons why
Me Too hit a tipping point.
Is that Me Too was generated
by women, basically
in Hollywood, that amplified
this phenomenon that
had been going on.
But it was driven
by those women,
and the men who have
supported it didn't co-opt it,
didn't control it,
didn't try to change it.
And I would just use that
as a metaphor that I think
is so important around
this idea, for me at least,
of inclusion.
When you're part of,
essentially, a privileged part
of the cycle is to try to be
an advocate and ally rather
than the controller or solver.
Which, again, for
a lot of people
in positions of privilege or
positions of power is hard.
That's a difficult frame
of reference to be in,
but it's a really
important starting point.
MARY GROVE: I
appreciate that so much.
I think it's exactly
the right way
to frame the challenge,
the opportunity.
And you guys have been at
the forefront of leading
on many parts.
And I think on the Techstars
Foundation piece specifically,
there are no other
organizations I
can think of who are investing--
it's almost like seed
funding for nonprofits who
are working towards diversity
inclusion in tech.
And so I applaud you and
thank you for those efforts.
I want to zoom out a bit
and talk about policy.
You're both active in advocating
for entrepreneur-friendly tech
policies.
What's the current climate
around tech policy?
Anything you're highlighting
for your entrepreneurs
at the moment and how they
can be active advocates?
DAVID COHEN: We're not being
sued by the government yet,
so that's good.
BRAD FELD: Speak for yourself.
No, I'm not right now.
Actually, there's an
emotional reaction
I have to the
question, so I'm going
to have the emotional
reaction first.
Government, especially
federal government,
makes me very tired.
And that's my
emotional reaction.
It makes me very tired not
because I'm cynical, angry,
unhappy, whatever.
It's just slow.
And that's actually
by design in the US.
Our democracy, one of the
operating principles of it
is it's hard to change things.
Lots of things change, but it's
hard to change the long arc
over time, for good or for bad.
Both sides of that.
So it is a thing that I've
learned by being involved
on a couple of vectors.
For me personally,
the two things
that I've cared the most
about as it applies to tech
are immigration reform
and patent reform.
On the immigration reform
front, personally, I
believe that a
human being should
be able to start a business
wherever in the world
they want.
And a human being
should be able to go
anywhere they want in the
world and work for where
they want to work.
That mobility, in the US, the
mobility across state borders
is something that's made our
country incredibly powerful.
The ability to have people
who for many, many years,
everybody wanted to come to
the US to start their business,
and the innovation engine of
the US was so enhanced by that.
The idea that there is
any meaningful friction
for somebody who wants to
come to the US to be able to,
number one, come to
the US, number two,
start a business in
US, is ludicrous to me.
If you wind the clock
back to even 2009, 2010,
if you're an entrepreneur
in another country,
and you want to
come to the US, you
have to navigate
this Byzantine system
to get the appropriate
visa to be able to start
your company in the US.
And there's very
few ways to do that.
It's very difficult.
And so there was a group
of us in 2009 or 2010
that started something
called the Startup Visa
Movement to try to get a visa
that allowed entrepreneurs
to come to the US to do it.
And one of the things
that stimulated
that for me personally was
two Techstars companies that
had non-US founders
in our second program.
Two of them were from Canada,
a really, really scary country.
Lots of dangerous
people up there.
DAVID COHEN: I'd build a
wall if I were them, yeah.
BRAD FELD: Yeah, I'd build--
if you were them right?
One direction.
And then the other
founders were from Europe.
The one I remember
was from France.
I think one was from England.
And after Techstars was over,
they wanted to stay in Boulder,
and they couldn't
get visas to stay
and had to go back to Canada and
Europe to run their companies,
and I thought that was insane.
So I've put a lot of
energy personally,
and I'd say sort of around
the system, within Techstars,
we've gotten reasonably
good at helping founders
that are non-US founders
be able to figure out
how to stay in the
US after they've
gone through the program.
But we've also expanded
geographically very
aggressively to
make sure there's
lots of places around the
world where we can engage.
From a policy
perspective, I think
this is the biggest
industry policy
issue that has to do with
long-term US competitiveness.
Because I think what's happening
on a very systematic basis,
you're already seeing
these massive shifts
of movement of capital to
other parts of the world.
And yes, the amount
of capital that's
being deployed against startups
and technology companies
is growing very
rapidly, but that ratio
is changing equally
rapidly away from the US.
And there are many,
many entrepreneurs
that I know internationally who
don't aspire to come to the US
to start their
companies anymore.
And I think that's a tough one.
The other one that I care about,
which is patents, I would say,
personally, the patent system
is so tangled up in itself
that it will just sort
of work itself over time.
There are, then,
second-order issues
which are happening, right?
Google, I know, is in the
midst of all the dynamics
around the election and
news and news curation.
You have this whole phenomenon
around cryptocurrency
and how to think
about cryptocurrency.
Many of these things are,
from my frame of reference,
around innovation, areas
where entrepreneurs should
be respectful of
the current context
that they're operating in.
Our advice is be
respectful of the context.
But at the same time, don't
be unwilling to challenge
whatever that context is.
I think a mistake that
plays out over and over
again is entrepreneurs ignore
the context completely, pretend
like the context either
doesn't exist or is irrelevant.
And then downstream,
you might end up
being very successful
as a business,
but you create
enormous an dislocation
in second-order
effects by not being
respectful of that
context going in.
MARY GROVE: Thank you, Brad.
Thank you.
I'm avid readers of
both of your blogs.
And, David, an
interesting post you
made, a comment about
making sure to have
a pessimist in the room.
Can you tell us a
bit more about that?
DAVID COHEN: Sure.
MARY GROVE: I think I
consider you an optimist.
DAVID COHEN: You have to be
to be an entrepreneur, right?
But it's also important
to surround yourself
with at least one person in a
decision-making context that's
not necessarily one of these
pessimists that's like,
that'll never work, but
more the, look, I'm really
worried about this or that.
And I think too
many entrepreneurs
surround themselves with people
that are like themselves.
Not enough diversity in
the room, diversity of
thought, in this case, to
where if you don't have that,
you end up just going
down the wrong path.
And it can be this
asymmetric risk where
that thing didn't work
out, and it ends up
blowing up everything.
And the stakes get high
as these companies grow.
And I just had a couple
of recent examples
of witnessing that.
And just a little
reminder, to have
somebody in the room that's
very smart, very respected,
that isn't necessarily
just an optimist, right?
That says, well, maybe
this could go wrong,
and let's at least think
about what could happen.
I've seen it save
companies, so that's
why I wanted to write about it.
MARY GROVE: That's great.
BRAD FELD: I'd add
one just quick thing.
It's important on the
dimension of diversity
that there is a whole
language around culture,
and you want to add people
to your company that
fit your culture.
And I think that's nonsensical.
If you are simply
adding people that
fit your culture, especially
as a startup, what you're doing
is you're homogenizing
your thinking,
and you're actually going to
sort of recede to the norm
in terms of your thinking.
You're not going to have people
challenging what's going on.
You might have different
frames of reference
on specific things,
but you're not
going to get a broader view.
The phrase we like to
use is culture add.
So instead of getting people
into your company that
fit your culture, everybody
that joins your company
adds to your culture.
And instead of using
the word culture,
I personally like to use
the phrase cultural norms.
Because there's a
difference between culture
and cultural norms.
And your cultural norms are
your stated value system,
the way you're going to
behave, that sort of thing.
And so if you're continually
adding to your cultural norms,
that's a pretty
dynamic thing, and that
will cause you to be more
inclusive of other frames
of reference, which
will also include
having people who
will tell you that, I
don't agree with that idea.
Versus a very consistent,
homogenized group,
which when you're three or four
people may or may not matter,
but when you're 20 or 30
people, has a big influence
on what goes from
30 people to 100
people in a successful place.
DAVID COHEN: And
on cultural add,
I first heard that from
Mitch and Freada Kapor.
Talk about that a lot.
And I think we've really
tried to adopt that and help
companies try to think
about things that way.
That's just a great way to
think about it differently.
MARY GROVE: It's a great
framework, cultural add.
So in a few minutes, I'm
going to switch over and take
questions from our audience,
if you want to start thinking
of those and teeing those up.
But just a couple of quick
fun ones while I have you.
I want to get some
life hacks here.
So tell us, when you're
not writing books,
what book are you
reading right now?
BRAD FELD: I am a fairly
promiscuous reader.
I read about 100
books a year, and I
read lots of different stuff.
My favorite books to
read are science fiction,
so I try to, every three or four
books, read or a random science
fiction book.
In terms of a recent book
that I read that was really
thought provoking was
a book from an MIT
series of shortish books--
100, 150 page books--
called "Post Truth."
And it's a series of books
around specific topics,
so they have a book
on robotics and a book
on artificial
intelligence that somebody
wrote that's sort of a primer.
And this one was on
this idea of post truth
and how postmodernism
and postmodernist thought
plays into the
way, today, we talk
about what is truth,
or what is fake news,
or what is not truth.
And that was an interesting one.
It had a lot of bias
in it too, by the way.
So you had to sort of
read through the bias.
Although the author exposed
his bias at the beginning.
So you're like,
this is his bias.
OK, I got his bias.
Oops, I bumped into
his bias again.
That was a good book.
One other book, if you're
interested at all in history
or interested in whatever
is happening currently,
is a book by Will
and Ariel Durant.
It's about 150 pages.
They're the ones that
wrote the 12-volume,
10,000-page books about
the history of society.
It's called "Lessons
of History."
And it's basically 10 short
chapters on different topics.
Government, education,
religion, morality.
And they used all
of human history
to show that it's the same
shit over and over again.
And in very, very short,
bite-sized chunks.
And it was actually
very-- for someone
who has regular moments of
anxiety around whatever's
happening, it's very reassuring
to read something like that
and realize that over the
course of human history,
yes, we've made progress
on a bunch of dimensions,
but yeah, a lot of
the shit's the same.
MARY GROVE: And we survived.
BRAD FELD: And we survived.
MARY GROVE: David, three
apps you can't live without.
DAVID COHEN: Oh, I was going
to give you the book one.
MARY GROVE: Oh, give
me the book one first.
DAVID COHEN: I'll just
give you the titles,
because they're so great.
MARY GROVE: OK.
DAVID COHEN: So the
one that our whole team
is reading right now, which
we do as a team sport--
I have no idea how you
read 100 books a year.
BRAD FELD: No kids.
DAVID COHEN: I guess.
That must be it.
BRAD FELD: I don't--
I don't need
electronic [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID COHEN: That's probably it.
Three kids.
"How We Decide," which is
emotional decision making,
which is an older book,
but super impactful
if you haven't read it.
And then the one that
really changed me recently
is called "The Soul of Money."
It's sort of you
are what you spend
and how you can use
money to have impact,
so really interesting.
Three apps?
I'll give you one,
and I'll try to think
of others while I give you one.
BRAD FELD: Gmail?
DAVID COHEN: Gmail, yeah.
You should use that one.
One that I use that actually
people don't know much about
is called Voxer.
It's voice message back
and forth really quick.
So we're 200 people all around
the world, a small company,
but very distributed.
The biggest office
is maybe 20 of us.
So it's a way to have
hallway conversations.
Brad's going to
demonstrate, apparently.
Just like on WhatsApp, it
has that tiny little button
that no one pushes
for the voice,
Voxer's got a big button,
and that's why I like it.
MARY GROVE: So you guys
use this within Techstars.
DAVID COHEN: We literally
run the company on it.
BRAD FELD: Hey, David, you
having fun with this At Google
thing right now?
DAVID COHEN: Yes.
MARY GROVE: I'm in the
middle of a great talk.
DAVID COHEN: So if
Voxer is listening,
they can totally tune into
the strategy of Techstars
just by stealing our
data and listening.
So that's a big one that
I think helps us a ton,
because when you're
so distributed,
you can't have that meaningful
conversation in the hallway.
So it lets us do
that, and I love it.
MARY GROVE: My last
question for you,
I'm just so curious
how you manage
your time, scale yourself.
We're always looking
for life hacks.
You talked earlier about
when you first met,
that Brad had a couple
of days set aside
for meetings with anyone
in 15-minute intervals.
Do you have any hacks,
tips for people who
are juggling a million things?
How do you prioritize
and run your life?
DAVID COHEN: Guess what?
Brad wrote a book.
He's a book salesman.
BRAD FELD: I am.
I could be.
Yeah, I wrote a
book with my wife.
DAVID COHEN: You have
a book on every topic.
BRAD FELD: Not quite.
Not quite.
I have a book I
wrote with my wife,
Amy Batchelor, called "Startup
Life: Surviving and Thriving
in a Relationship with an
Entrepreneur" is the subtitle.
So if that sings to you, it's
available at all booksellers
named Amazon.
And others as well.
And there's a bunch of hacks
in that book, by the way.
Amy and I do a thing called
four minutes in the morning,
where each morning, we
spend four minutes together,
first thing, just getting set.
We don't have kids, but
we play with our dogs,
and we talk, and sometimes we
have a cup of coffee together.
But it's linked to
whoever wakes up last.
So who ever wakes
up last, that's
a prompt for the person
who woke up first
to stop whatever they're
doing and just spend
a few minutes together as a
way of grounding ourselves
in our relationship.
DAVID COHEN: You can also do it
in three minutes, to save time.
Don't use four.
It's another hack.
BRAD FELD: The
most profound thing
that I've incorporated into
my life in the last couple
of years around this is I used
to be that person who woke up
at 5 o'clock in the morning
every morning, no matter
what time zone I was in.
I worked all the
time, the 24/7 thing.
And I had ego
attachment to the fact
that I was always
getting up at 5 o'clock,
even if I flew
cross-country and needed
to sleep for another
couple hours.
And I was always available.
I try to be very responsive to
email, try to always engage.
And I'm Jewish,
but not religious.
And I got very depressed
at the end of 2012
and about a six-month
depressive episode in 2013.
And some of that
was just-- there
were a bunch things
that played into it,
and I'll leave that
riff for another day.
But two things that
I did that were
really powerful life
hacks is I stopped
waking up with an alarm clock.
And what happened was I
slept 12 hours or more
a day, every day, for
the next six months.
So I did not realize
how physiologically
exhausted I was.
And I love sleep.
And so I'm really
now very focused
on making sure that
on a regular basis
I'm getting at least eight
hours of sleep a night.
So valuing sleep,
especially as you
start to get a little bit older.
There's a good book
about this that
relatively recently came out.
But there's just so
much evidence now
that sleep is a
critically important thing
around both physical
health, mental health,
and productivity,
like your ability
to concentrate for
extended periods of time.
The other thing
that was profound
for me on this dimension is--
and it ties back into
the Jewish thing--
is that I started having
a digital Sabbath.
So from Friday night
sundown to Saturday night
sundown, no email, no
phone calls, no meetings.
I just have time for me,
for Amy, for my dogs,
for friends, for reading.
That's how I read so much.
DAVID COHEN: No kids.
BRAD FELD: No kids.
But if I had kids, I
would play with my kids.
Or I'd give them
to somebody else,
so I'd have some free time.
Actually, I'd probably
sell them if I had kids.
DAVID COHEN: I'll bring my
kids over to your place.
BRAD FELD: Please don't do that.
But that one day
a week of complete
disconnect from the digital
world that we're in has--
I don't watch television.
I just disconnect.
And I have time for myself.
The first four or five months
of doing that each weekend is
excruciating, right?
Like, oh my god.
I might miss an email.
It's only 9:15.
I've got a whole fucking day
still to not check my email.
But after a while, you
really get into this place
where it creates an
enormous amount of space.
And when you sort of
reengage with the world,
and I often stretch
it to Sunday morning.
I kind of reengage with
the world Sunday morning.
What you start realizing
is you didn't miss much.
And every now and then, there
might be something that, eh,
might have been additive if
you had some involvement.
And there's occasionally things
that I have project stuff
that I have to do on Saturday.
But the point I would
make of this life hack
is making sure you're giving
yourself real time each week
for you, however you do it.
And I saw a phrase in
a book somebody else
wrote that I'm proofreading for
him or giving a pre-read for.
That he shifted
from 24/7 to 24/6.
And I love that idea.
And I don't care whether
you distribute the 24
hours across the week, or you--
I think it's easier to
distribute across a day.
But to disconnect
from all the nonsense
that we're dealing with all
the time and all the stimuli,
so that we can remember
that we're human,
and we can spend time with the
people we want to spend time
with, especially ourselves.
And allow you to
then have the energy
to go after the next six days
of whatever that intensity is
has been a big one for me.
DAVID COHEN: So you message to
Google employees, work less.
MARY GROVE: Work
less, sleep more.
As a mom of one-year-old twins,
Brad, your comment about sleep
is making me very,
very, nervous.
BRAD FELD: [LAUGHS]
MARY GROVE: David, any
quick hacks to add?
DAVID COHEN: One
hack is if you're
going to write a
bunch of books, you
should totally outsource
the chapters of those books
to others, like Brad did
with the "Startup Life" book.
"Startup Relationship."
BRAD FELD: Yeah, all my books.
DAVID COHEN: What's
the title of that one?
"Startup Life"?
BRAD FELD: "Startup Life," yeah.
If you read any of
my books, there's
a bunch of sidebars in them.
And basically, a
typical hardback book
is about 50,000 words.
And I figured out that
you can get other people
to write about 20,000
of the 50,000 words.
DAVID COHEN: So you got
me to write the chapter
in that book, which was
"Always have a light
at the end of the tunnel."
You know, we get in
these periods of time
where we work really hard,
and I've found, in my family,
just knowing there's
always a thing coming up
that's really exciting, a trip,
or time off, or whatever it is.
Just don't ever not
have one of those,
no matter how far out it
is, and it helps everybody
stay sane in the context
of these busy periods
that we all go through.
MARY GROVE: Great advice.
Great advice.
Thank you.
Any live questions
from our Googlers?
Yes.
SPEAKER: I have a
microphone here,
if people have any questions.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, guys.
It was fantastic
to have you here.
I find myself thinking
a lot about something
you said at the beginning, Brad.
In all the new
projects that I start,
I find myself pushing
and pushing and pushing.
And then you were talking
about the dynamic of pulling.
How do you think about that?
Is it an indicator that
this is a normal thing?
You have to push
in the beginning?
Or maybe my ideas
are not so great?
BRAD FELD: Well,
I actually think
most ideas at the beginning
are totally irrelevant.
Right?
And they're just way overrated.
You start with an idea, and--
my partners and I
joke about this.
I have a hundred shitty
ideas for every good idea
that I have.
And the thing that
works its magic is I
let the hundred
shitty ideas out.
I don't hold them, or I
don't grab the first one
and then anchor on and try
to turn it into a good idea.
Now, in the context of a
project, you could say, well,
but this is a project I'm
going to be working on
for six months.
That's the thing.
And what I would say
is break it down,
like an engineering problem.
Make it reductionist into
lots of little ideas.
And run lots of little
experiments, knowing
that most of the experiments
are going to fail,
or most of your hypotheses
are wrong early on.
And you're running
a bunch of them
because you're looking
for one to grab hold.
Now, another mistake would be
to assume that pull is something
that happens programmatically.
Yeah, you have to go
out there and hustle.
You have to talk to people.
You have to experiment.
You have to try
to convince people
that this is interesting
for them to even try it.
And if you do that,
and time after time,
quickly, it's all
not interesting,
and you're not getting
any feedback back,
that's a problem.
If you're getting
feedback back, then you're
constantly adjusting.
Right?
And so you're playing
that hundred ideas
until you get the
thing that you land on
where all of a sudden,
people are pulling.
So at the very
beginning, no, you're
not going to have something
spring fully formed out
of your mind that everybody's
going to get excited about,
and if they don't, you
should walk away from it.
But try to keep breaking
it down into smaller
and smaller chunks.
The experiments that are
causing you to learn and modify
the fundamental premise of your
idea until all of a sudden,
you find people trying to
rip it out of your hands.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
being here, guys.
I was a former
Techstars participant.
So thank you for
organizing that.
I guess the question
I had top of mind,
what does success look like
for you guys for Techstars
in like 10 years?
Where do you want
to see yourselves,
and what impact do you
want to have on the world?
DAVID COHEN: Yeah.
So when we think about
building this big network,
it's really helping more
entrepreneurs to succeed.
So figuring out more
ways to do that.
Certainly, it's more worldwide.
We want to be investing
in many more places.
Today, 400 companies a year.
We want to really
see that scale.
And I think we need to
help them in more parts
of the entrepreneurial journey.
So today we have products that
are very helpful in the very
early stages.
We get a little
bit helpful as they
grow, and then
eventually, we hope maybe
someone else comes
along and is great
and helps that company succeed.
And connecting them to those
people is part of what we do.
But I think we can
play more of a role
in showing the world that
there are going to be
more great startup communities.
That great companies are
going to be built everywhere.
And that there is
a role, perhaps, we
can play throughout that
entire journey and not just
at the beginning of it.
MARY GROVE: We have time for
one final question in the back.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So Techstars obviously has
a huge mentor and volunteer
network and so on.
And if you had to
give advice to someone
who wants to build
the necessary skills
to get into that
space, what would
you say that they
start off with?
DAVID COHEN: When you say
that space, you mean--
AUDIENCE: Just like in
the accelerator space,
as a mentor, as a
volunteer and so on.
So what kind of
skills would you say
that they should start off
with or start building on?
DAVID COHEN: To become a mentor
and help other entrepreneurs.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID COHEN: Yeah.
So there's a post
that I guess I curated
on my blog, a lot of
people contributed to,
called "The Mentor
Manifesto," that we
try to list what is it that you
should be doing as a mentor.
And I think one of
the things that people
think about when they hear that
word is that this is somehow--
you've been a person that's
built a billion-dollar company,
and you've had this
amazing outcome.
My argument is not
everybody's a mentor.
Every single person
in this room,
there's someone who knows
a lot more about something
than I would know
about that thing.
So everybody has
something to contribute,
some expertise, some
advice that they're
speaking from experience on.
I think that's the key to being
a good mentor is recognizing,
where do my experiences lie?
What areas can I be helpful in?
And it's OK that I
don't know everything.
I can come and be helpful
in a context in a situation.
But "The Mentor Manifesto"
does a pretty good job
of laying out what I think of
as the social norms for being
a mentor.
Don't come in and try to
answer all the questions.
Try to stay in the
areas you understand.
Listen as much as you talk.
And there's a whole
list of things
that you can read
about in that post.
But I think everybody can
contribute to the success
of others in that way.
BRAD FELD: One thing to add to
that is practical things you
can do is engage and do things
with other people who are
interested in entrepreneurship.
Startup Weekend is a
great example of it.
Go do stuff.
Like reading, watching
videos, talking to people,
trying to learn on
the receiving side
is so different than
actively practicing
the activity of
entrepreneurship,
especially if your mentor
engagement is not necessarily
as an entrepreneur,
but as a domain
expert in some
area where you can
help other entrepreneurs because
of your domain expertise.
Understanding how
entrepreneurs think, work,
what it feels like by doing
is so much more visceral
than observing or studying it.
AUDIENCE: I've got it.
Thank you.
MARY GROVE: David,
Brad, thank you
so much for your time today.
Thank you for all that
you do for the ecosystem.
I see Don Loeb, John
Beetle from Techstars here.
Thank you to the whole team, and
thanks for being a great Google
partner.
BRAD FELD: Thank you, Mary.
DAVID COHEN: Thanks
for having us.
[APPLAUSE]